JESSE: On Prime Crime.
JESSE: Two deaths
bring new questions
for a family dynasty.
WOMAN: A lot
of people respect them,
but there are some
people who fear them.
JESSE: The evidence.
JESSE: The testimony.
He was pacing back and forth
and he said:
"I got a bad feeling."
JESSE:
And the incredible moments.
Hey there, everybody.
I'm Jesse Weber
and welcome to Prime Crime.
This is where we break down
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases.
Our next story takes us
to South Carolina,
where controversy,
speculation and even death
surround one family.
JESSE: South Carolina,
June 7, 2021, 10:07 p.m.
JESSE: Attorney Alex Murdaugh
tells the 911 dispatcher
that his wife,
52-year-old Maggie,
and son, 22-year-old Paul
are shot dead
at their family property
known as Moselle.
Paul and Maggie were
found down at the kennels.
ANGENETTE: Paul had been
shot with a shotgun,
shot in the chest first,
the fatal injury
was to his head.
Maggie meanwhile suffered
five gunshot wounds
from what they said
was a 300 blackout rifle.
Using that type of ammunition.
JESSE: But who
could've done this?
In order
to understand the murders
we have to understand a bit more
about the Murdaugh family.
The Murdaugh family
has been prominent
in the low country of
South Carolina for a century.
ANGENETTE: Three
generations of Murdaughs
prior to Alex Murdaugh
were solicitors,
basically the prosecutors.
They were basically
the face of law enforcement
in that community.
A lot of people respect them
and revere them, but there
are some people who fear them.
JESSE: Controversy, rumors
and even death surrounded
the Murdaugh family,
such as the sudden demise
of their family housekeeper,
Gloria Satterfield in 2018.
ERIC: According to what Alex
told the insurance adjuster,
that his dogs greeted her
at the top of the step,
which caused her
to fall backwards.
And that's the only
known statement of that.
JESSE: Then
there's the mysterious death
of 19-year-old Stephen Smith,
found on a South Carolina
road in 2015.
The state troopers
who were on the scene
that morning didn't believe
this was a hit and run.
ERIC: His shoes
would've been blown off,
there would've been skid marks,
there would've been some debris.
So I think it was
blunt-force trauma and I think
he was dumped off
in the middle of the road.
ANGENETTE: He was
an openly gay teenager
and he had attended
high school there in Hampton
with Buster Murdaugh.
Randy Murdaugh,
Alex Murdaugh's older brother,
apparently reached out
to Sandy Smith,
the mother of Stephen, and said:
"I will offer to represent you".
And Sandy Smith
really didn't understand
why she would need any
representation at that point.
ERIC: Alex and Randy, either one
or both, were on the scene.
How would he know
to show up to an accident scene?
Buster says that he had
nothing to do with his murder.
I'll take him at his word.
JESSE: But there's something
else from the Murdaugh past.
Something from 2019
that Alex immediately
mentions to first
responder Sgt. Greene.
ANGENETTE: Paul Murdaugh
and his friends went out.
They were in his father's boat,
there were people on the boat
who said: "Let me drive,
you've had too much to drink",
and, you know,
the reports we've heard
was that Paul said:
"No, this is my boat."
The boat then crashes.
That resulted
in the death of Mallory Beach.
He was indicted on boating
while under the influence.
JESSE: Is it
possible Paul and Maggie
were murdered
by enemies of the family?
Fast forward almost
three months after the killings.
911 receive another call
from Alex Murdaugh.
People start to think:
"Oh my God, like,
"somebody is
out to kill this family."
JESSE: But
as you're about to see,
sometimes in cases
things aren't exactly
what they seem.
Days later, Alex Murdaugh comes
clean and says: "You know what?
"Some guy didn't shoot me.
"I asked Curtis Eddie Smith,
this guy I know, to shoot me."
I wanted to commit
suicide or be assisted
in committing suicide,
so my son Buster
could get ten million dollars
from a life insurance policy.
Alex Murdaugh admits: "I've had
an opioid addiction for years",
and so he 'fesses up
and he's arrested for this.
JESSE: And when
investigators dig deeper,
they find that Alex Murdaugh
was not the man
that the community
thought him to be.
Indictments come out
for Alex. Charges for
a number of financial crimes,
tax evasion,
stealing from clients,
stealing from the law firm.
JESSE: Alex Murdaugh
would eventually be charged
with over 90
financial-related crimes,
including embezzlement,
money laundering and conspiracy.
But what else
could he be hiding?
Could he in any way be behind
the killings of Maggie and Paul?
(tense music)
JESSE: On June 7th, 2021,
Maggie and Paul Murdaugh
are found shot to death
on their family property
in South Carolina.
Maggie's husband and
Paul's father, Alex Murdaugh,
calls 911 to report
discovering their bodies.
JESSE: While Alex
initially appears
to be an innocent victim,
during the course
of the investigation
it's revealed
he had been stealing
from his law firm and clients
and orchestrated a suicide plot
to conduct insurance fraud.
As he was criminally charged for
these alleged financial crimes,
the question became,
is he hiding something else?
Is it possible he was
behind the killings too?
JESSE: Through a series of
interviews with law enforcement,
Murdaugh lays out his activities
on the night of the murders.
JESSE: There are
some odd things, though,
about Alex Murdaugh.
For instance,
the footage you're seeing
is from a Snapchat video
that was taken off of
Paul's phone earlier in
the night before the murders.
Now compare
that to what Murdaugh
is wearing later on in
the evening after the killings.
No one knows what happened
to that blue shirt
that Alex was wearing
in the Snapchat video.
JESSE: And let's talk about
that timeline of the night.
The Cellebrite analysis shows
that Maggie Murdaugh's phone
locked at 8:49 p.m.
So did Paul Murdaugh's phone.
It doesn't appear
that either one of them
pick up their
cell phones again.
JESSE: Based
on this cell phone data,
investigators believe
the killings happened
between 8:49 and 9:06 p.m.
And they also say someone,
possibly the killer,
was manipulating Maggie's
phone before throwing it
on the side of the road
where it's ultimately found.
After nearly
an hour of no activity,
Murdaugh's phone suddenly
records a flurry of steps
before he drives away
from the property.
And, in fact, data
from Murdaugh's car
not only shows him
driving past the location
where Maggie's phone was tossed,
but so much more.
ANGENETTE: The data also
shows that Alex Murdaugh
is at his mother's home
for about 15 to 20 minutes.
JESSE: And speaking of
questionable comments to police,
there was this exchange that
had a lot of people talking.
You know it sounds like
"They did him so bad,"
but a lot of other people
thought he said:
"I did them so bad."
That would be...
tantamount to a confession.
JESSE: However, let's go
back to Murdaugh's alibi.
ANGENETTE: He
was with his family,
he took a nap,
then he goes to his mom's.
He said he had not
been at the kennels.
JESSE: Late
in the investigation,
authorities
find something hidden
on Paul's phone,
a video recorded at 8:44 p.m.,
approximately five minutes
before prosecutors say
Maggie and Paul were shot.
A video that changes
this whole story.
At 8:44 p.m., he told
law enforcement he was asleep,
so this totally blows up
his timeline and his alibi.
It was the single most
important piece of evidence.
It's Paul speaking
from the grave.
JESSE: On July 14th, 2022,
Alex Murdaugh was
officially indicted
for the murders of
Paul and Maggie Murdaugh.
Up next,
a trial unlike any other.
The gallery was packed.
People were lining up
at 2:00 in the morning
to make sure
that they got a spot.
(tense music)
JESSE: It's January 2023,
the start of the murder trial
of Alex Murdaugh,
the once prominent
South Carolina attorney
now accused of shooting to death
his wife Maggie and son Paul
on their family property
back in June of 2021.
The same man who was
separately charged with dozens
of financial-related crimes
for stealing money
from his law firm clients
and the government.
This trial was
watched by the nation
as the prosecution
and the defense battled it out.
About 8:50 p.m.
and the defendant over there,
Alex Murdaugh,
took a 12-gauge shotgun
and shot him.
Just moments later,
he picked a 300 blackout
and opened fire
on his wife Maggie.
PROSECUTOR: Family weapons were
used to murder Maggie and Paul.
ANGENETTE: The murder weapons
were never found,
but the examiner
from SLED did say he believed
the same 300 blackout rifle
that killed Maggie Murdaugh
was likely the same
300 blackout rifle
that had fired
300 blackout rounds
up by the house months prior.
JESSE: Prosecutors
would present the case
that Murdaugh had
the means and opportunity
to kill his family
on their property.
They pinpointed his questionable
activities through phone
and car data suggesting
he moved quickly to
cover his tracks and alibi.
But they also
argue that Murdaugh
lied to investigators.
How long did he stay
in the room with y'all?
And I say y'all
for the record,
you and Ms. Libby, I apologize.
About 15 to 20 minutes.
- Twenty minutes.
JESSE: And prosecutors
would also claim Murdaugh
tried to influence
the accounts of key witnesses.
He was pacing
back and forth in the,
in the living room and he said:
"I got a bad feeling."
There was a video
that was out, and he said:
"You remember
the shirt I was wearing?
That Vinny Vine shirt?"
In my mind I was saying,
"I don't remember
a Vinny Vine's shirt,
it was the polo shirt."
BLANCA: I didn't really know
whether he was trying to...
get me to say that that was
the shirt he was wearing.
JESSE: Yet arguably
the state's strongest piece
of evidence was
the infamous kennel video.
The recording
taken off of Paul's phone
that places Alex Murdaugh
at the crime scene
minutes before
Paul and Maggie were murdered.
The one question that remained
is why would Alex Murdaugh
kill his wife and son.
The motive was
he had financial pressure
bearing down on him
in June of 2021
from a number of sources.
So now it was gonna come out,
most likely, that he had
stolen 3.5 million dollars.
The law firm
confronted him on June 7,
the day of Paul
and Maggie's murders.
And they said there's
792,000 dollars missing.
I said: "I have reason
to believe
"that you received the
Ferris money directly to you
"and you need to prove
to me that you did not."
ERIC: The state
felt he needed to divert
the attention away from
all these financial pressures.
JESSE: And then,
there was the defense.
There's no direct evidence,
there's no eyewitness.
There's no camera,
there's no fingerprints,
there's no forensics
tying him to the crime. None!
There were a number of things
coming into this trial that
that seemed to be problematic
for the prosecution.
ATTORNEY:
There's no blood on him.
They didn't find
any blood on him.
JOE: What's the explanation
for not having blood on himself?
This would've
been a bloody mess.
JESSE: The defense also
argued that the state's theory
of the shooting could be off.
My opinion is
the totality of the evidence
is more suggestive
of a two-shooter scenario.
TIMOTHY: Why would one shooter
bring two long rifles,
two long weapons to the event?
You can't handle
and shoot two of them.
Whoever shot this shot
or the shot, well,
first of all the (inaudible)
shot was 5.2 to 5.4.
MIKE: That is the most
likely explanation, yes.
I think the defense
presented evidence
to try to show
that Alex Murdaugh
really didn't fit
the build of the person
who committed the murders
because of the evidence
we heard about trajectory.
JESSE: They also suggested
this investigation was botched.
But there was
a body footprint near his
that turned out to be
law enforcement, correct?
Yes.
ATTORNEY: Is that
preservation of the scene
that new standards require?
MELINDA: Not exactly, no.
Do we know what other evidence
they may have destroyed?
I have no idea.
That's right, we don't.
JESSE: When we come back
this whole trial changes
when one person decides
it's time for the jury
to hear his side of the story.
- JUDGE: What is your decision?
- I am going to testify,
I want to testify.
(tense music)
The evidence will show
he killed Maggie and Paul.
Here is the law.
He didn't do it.
JESSE: In early 2023,
the world watched
the Alex Murdaugh
murder trial unfold.
The once prominent
attorney now accused
of shooting to death
his wife Maggie and son Paul
by the dog kennels
on their family property.
The prosecution presented
compelling evidence,
such as video from
Paul's phone placing Murdaugh
at the crime scene
minutes before the killings.
They also suggested
that Murdaugh,
a substance abuser and defendant
in separate
financial-related crime cases,
of killing his family because
he was about to be exposed
for stealing money
from his law firm and clients
and the murders
would be a distraction
and buy him some time.
Well, there was one man
who wanted to set
the record straight and
that was Alex Murdaugh himself.
Mr. Griffin, I didn't shoot
my wife or my son any time.
- Ever.
- JESSE: And that is
when Alex Murdaugh
shocked everyone.
Mr. Murdaugh is
that you on the kennel video?
It is.
Were you in fact
at the kennels at 8:44 p.m.
- I was.
- Did you lie
to SLED agent Owen
and deputy Laura Rutland?
I did lie to them.
I don't think
Alex Murdaugh had any choice
but to take the stand
because of the kennel video.
He had to explain why he lied.
As my addiction
evolved over time...
I would get any
situations or circumstances
where I would get paranoid.
He did really quite
well in my opinion.
I thought credible,
believable...
showed appropriate emotion.
JESSE: He even
seemingly admitted
to the financial crimes
he was accused of perpetrating.
I stole money
that was not my money.
I misled people that I shouldn't
have misled, and I did wrong.
He's a liar and he's a thief
and he readily admitted
that on the stand.
But he said, you know:
"I might be these things,
"but I didn't
kill my wife and son".
JESSE: When Murdaugh says
he was at the crime scene
he claims he left
right before the murders.
However,
prosecutor Creighton Waters
wasn't having it.
The reality is, Mr. Murdaugh,
is the reason why no one's ever
heard that before is because
you had to sit in this courtroom
and hear your family
and your friends
one after the other come in
and testify that you were on
that kennel video, so you,
like you've done so many times
over the course of your life,
had to back up and make a
new story that kind
of fit with the facts
that can't be denied.
Isn't that true, sir?
No, sir, that's not true.
Putting Alex on the stand
was the single dumbest move
I've ever seen when you have
a guy that's an admitted liar.
WOMAN: Indictment
for murder, guilty verdict.
JAMES: There's a lot of evidence
that points towards Alex.
He can't, you know,
deny that he was there
at that point because there's
a video that places him there.
Somebody that couldn't speak,
somebody that couldn't be a
witness was able to
be a witness even
after they passed away.
JAMES: I think that he's
good at being able to talk to
people and I think that
whenever he's convincing,
he's convincing himself as well.
And I think he's able
to do that because he often
meshes the truth with a lie.
Mr. Murdaugh I sentence you,
in the murder of your wife
Maggie Murdaugh,
I sentence you for the term
of the rest
of your natural life.
For the murder of Paul Murdaugh,
whom you probably loved so much,
I sentence you to prison
for murdering him
for the rest
of your natural life.
JESSE: Alex Murdaugh's legal
team intends to appeal the case,
but right after the trial ended,
a new update surfaced
in the story of Stephen Smith,
whose death fueled rumors
of a Murdaugh family connection.
ERIC: I'd been asleep
and when I woke up,
I saw that there were
three phone calls
from chief Mark Keel
and he said: "Well,
"I'm gonna communicate
to you now
"the state of South Carolina's
official position
"and that is
Stephen Smiths did not die
"as a result of a vehicle
accident or collision.
"He was, in fact,
the victim of a homicide
"and we're committed
to finding out
"who killed Stephen Smith."
At the time of this recording,
the Alex Murdaugh
conversation is continuing.
There's still his appeal,
the Stephen Smith investigation,
upcoming financial crimes cases.
Look, there are many things
that could be said
about Alex Murdaugh,
yet more than anything,
he is just
another example of someone
who is not above the law.
That's all we have
for you here on Prime Crime.
Thank you for joining us
and until next time, stay safe.
(tense music)